من الصعب جدا وذم مجهود العمر كله من
الشهادات والوثائق الاكاديميه لكن مشاعر
قويه دفعته الى اخذ هذا القرار الصعب كما
يقول اسماعيل مشعل الاستاذ الجامعي الذي
مزق شهاداته في برنامج متلفزن ردا على
قرار طالبانا بمنع الفتيات من
التعليميات الى ان استطيع واتمكن من
الكفاح الذي بداته من اجل سيدات اللواتي
يبلغ عددهن 20 مليون
فريد احمد من زملائي مشعل في العمليه
التعليميه استاذ جامعي لكنه قدم استقاله
من مهامه التعليميه في الجامعه ايضا يكافح
مع مشعل جنبا الى جنب لاسترجاع الحقوق
التعليميه المشروعه للفتيات
لن نرجع الى مهمتنا المقدسه مهمه التدريس
حتى تفتح جميع باب المدارس والمعاهد
والجامعات امام جميع الفتيات في جميع
افغانستان
اسماعيل مشعل يملك حاليا مدرسه ابتدائيه
ومعهدا وجامعه يقول انه عنتر الجميع هذه
المشاريع التعليميه تضامنا مع الفتيات
الافغانيات ويشتغل في مؤسسته الخيريه التي
تقدم خدمات انسانيه
للمحتاجين في المجتمع الافغاني على اي حال
ليس نادما على تمزيقه شهادات لكن صنيعه
ياتي لوجه رساله لفظ لقرار منع تعليم
الفتيات وهو يعلم ان ما فعله لن يثني
طالبانا عن قرارها قبل نادر العربيه كابول